don't cry because it's over
smile because it happened
when something bad happens you have
three choices
you can either let it Define you
let it destroy you
or you can let it strengthen you
the right direction for success and
personal growth is the path that leads
us to the answers within ourselves
listen to these quotes by Dr Seuss to
enrich your life with his quotes
sometimes you will never know the value
of a moment
until it becomes a memory
you have to be odd to be number one
to the world you may be one person but
to one person you may be the world
life is too short to wake up in the
morning with regrets
it is better to know how to learn than
to know
why fit in when you were born to stand
out
be sure when you step
with care and great tact
and remember that life is a great
Balancing Act
who you are and say what you feel
because those who mind don't matter
and those who matter
don't mind
sometimes the questions are complicated
and the answers are simple
take every chance
drop every fear
a person's a person
no matter how small
today you are you
that is truer than true
there is no one alive that is your than
you
everything stinks until it's finished
in your head is your brain
your feet are in your shoes
you are in control of which direction to
go
you are on your own
and you know what you know
and only you can decide where to go
only you can control your future
always remember you are braver than you
believe
stronger than you seem
smarter than you think and twice as
beautiful as you've ever imagined
it is fun to have fun
but you have to know how
when a man does something stupid once
wealth that's because he's a man
but if he does the same stupid thing
twice
that's usually to impress some lady
you can get help from teachers
but you are going to have to learn a lot
by yourself
sitting alone in a room
reading can take you places you have
never been before
I like nonsense
it wakes up the brain cells
looking at life through the perspective
of a child
enables you to laugh at life's realities
nothing is going to change
unless someone does something soon
everybody should be treated equally and
with dignity no matter the circumstance
instead of focusing on areas of
improvement
hone in on your strengths
you will be happier and more fulfilled
than ever before
if you always have faith and trust in
yourself there's no limit to the places
you will go
people will start missing you when they
see how happy you are without them
fill your house with stacks of books
in all the crannies and all the Nooks
you're off to great places
today is your day
your mountain is waiting
so get on your way
we have collected these quotes by the
prolific children's book author Dr Seuss
his views and quotes about childhood and
adulthood should be a non-changeable
part of our lives